Kids get to popcorn now let me tell you the
story of the space viking thor odenson he
he reclaimed his title as the one
and only thor oh spook too soon jane
well you're right
the only ones who gods care about
is themselves
so this is my vow all gods will die
not like the first gods earth kill because
i have something worth fighting for
let's see who you are and take
off your disguise and flick
oh you flick too hard damn it
should we help him mean eventually great
Welcome back everyone we have a brand new thor
love and thunder trailer to break down there's
a whole bunch of easter eggs we finally got our
first look at gorr the god butcher christian bale
he is going to wreck most of the mcu gods before
thor gets to him with an axe in the face his body
is dissolving in a bathtub in hell's kitchen just
had to kill a lot of people if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we'll just start at the beginning of the trailer
and work our way through shot by shot talking
about easter eggs wtf moments as we go along
they start with a brand new scene of korg
telling the story of thor in his life to
these small children part of this blue alien
race they could be centaurians there aren't
that many blue aliens besides cree inside the mcu
that we've seen so far besides the centaurians
that'd be yondu's race he's like the other blue
skinned alien that we know he's wearing his brand
new costume you see in the background that giant
tree that thor is sitting under as he's trying
to meditate about what he should do with his
life he's talking about being more peaceful
but really he's called to action because of
what's happening with gorr the god butcher
and they have the funny moment where they reveal
him learning about jane foster's version of thor
and mjolnir for the first time like he's all happy
to see it and he's wearing his brand new helmet
the blue version of the costume is like the second
upgrade that he gets we see a couple different
costumes that he gets throughout the trailer he
goes from the 80s looking eric masterson version
of thor with the jacket it's like his ravager's
costume he's called ravager thor when he wears
this he has like a mjolnir inspired t-shirt
he has the gold boots from the classic thor
comics that we also see in the trailer when he's
younger he gets all swole again but then he gets
another costume upgrade like he slams the hammer
down like we saw during ragnarok changing the
appearance of his costume he goes to his second
upgrade where he has the pelt on but then when
he sees jane foster thor for the first time after
he's gone back to new asgard and he's wearing his
second upgrade the blue looking rune king
thor like most powerful thor upgrade costume
he's got a much bigger version of the helmet
with the wings on which is also a big comic
book easter egg he's just meant to look like
the most powerful that thor has ever become
like everybody gets costume upgrades in their
movies but they play the same avengers endgame
joke that they did with captain america where
he's like reaching for mjolnir and you think
that he's gonna take it but then it goes to
the other person in this case it just happens
to be jane foster he reclaimed his title as
the one and only thor oh spook too soon jane
it doesn't seem like they're modulating
her voice at all like she still speaks
like natalie portman's character does in the
other thor movies you may have realized that
joke that he says about not having seen her in
eight plus years is actually him talking about
seeing her during the events of thor the dark
world but it was during the avengers end game
time heist that's technically the most recent time
he's seen her the joke about saving planet earth
for the 500th time isn't meant to be a lie because
he's over 1500 years old so he visited earth many
times before the events of the modern day mcu
movies they have a much longer version of the
workout montage with a couple different scenes of
him losing all that weight from avengers end game
it's the same version of the guns and roses
song from the first trailer sweet child of mine
they're using 80s music because it's an 80s
inspired genre that they're going for in the movie
like that's why all the titles are inspired by the
80s thor titles that's why during the movie he's
wearing the eric masterson 80s looking costume for
the ravagers all these people that he's fighting
when he comes back to new asgard is just a
version of gorr's army that he has working for him
now the weird thing that they do though when
they reveal jane foster thor is that he goes
from the old version of the upgraded costume
to the brand newest blue gold looking costume
when he's learning about jane foster thor for the
first time like he sees mjolnir in the old costume
but then when he's reacting to jane foster in the
trailer he's already gotten the costume upgrade
so there's some missing footage in here that
we're not seeing like something happens he does to
upgrade his costume again get even more power but
all this destruction behind them all these burning
buildings this is all meant to be new asgard you
see a version of valkyrie riding on our horse in
the sky a lot of people asking if they're going
to revive the valkyries just in general at the
end of this movie it's always possible they've
also said they've given valkyrie some extra
powers in this movie too as she's become king of
asgard you also see her using zeus's lightning
bolt when she's fighting gorr at the end of the
trailer so i'll talk about that in a second too
they make all these jokes about remembering your
first time how it's so special mostly talking
about jane foster the first time he fell in love
but everybody knows what they're really talking
about this big hall that she crashes down into
underground where you see her looking around these
giant heads it looks like a bunch of dead gods i
think it's just meant to be another place of power
that's meant to reference a lot of the other mcu
gods that gorr has been going after and killing
because like zoom in enhanced behind her here
you actually see this shroud over this one head
that's actually the living tribunal we just saw
a version of that during doctor strange too like
during the sequence of them traveling between
universes they fly right past the heads of the
living tribunal so it sounds like this place
is just a place of great cosmic significance
not just to the gods like one of these heads is a
skeletal looking head so it's meant to represent
gods of different aspects of creation and reality
there's a whole bunch of brand new scenes of all
of them at mount olympus like their version of
mount olympus exists the same way that asgard
exists it's like this different planetoid that you
have to travel to it looks like we see valkyrie in
her armor picking up thor in his old ravager's
costume on this trash looking planet after some
battle with the guardians of the galaxy he has
that funny conversation with star-lord about
finding what he loves people wondered if there
was a missing character in this scene now it
seems like they're confirming that valkyrie is
here and she's trying to get thor to come back
to new asgard in this scene in the trailer
with the cage you can see a version of thor
inside it just seems like a planetoid that gorr
has used to try and kill some of the other gods
like he's trapped thor here while he's waiting to
kill him then they finally reveal christian bale's
gorr the god butcher with the version of cg that
we're gonna see during the movie and his version
of the necro sword so a lot of you asked about the
necro sword is it going to be like the comics is
it going to be any kind of no backstory because in
the comics they actually retcon the necrosaur to
be the primal symbiote which wound up being a big
venom and null easter egg for the comics i'm not
expecting them to invoke the null character so i
think it's just going to be a version of the necro
sword and it probably just winds up being a cosmic
artifact that gives him the power he needs to kill
gods i am a little surprised that they didn't make
him look like full gorr in the comics like they
made his face look kind of like christian bale's
face he is meant to be part of a different race
of people in the galaxy but a lot of his story
during the trailer is basically his comic book
story they're trying to be pretty authentic to
that he has a family who winds up dying this
senseless death and when he learns of the
true existence of his own people's gods and
that they did nothing to stop it he learns that
most of the gods around the mcu are pretty lazy
don't really get involved with the affairs of man
don't care about their followers so when he finds
the necro sword he goes on a quest to kill them
all slowly he goes full american psycho on all
the mcu gods there were brief references to this
during moon knight where they said two of the
gods that were part of their pantheon conscious
pantheon had gone missing that's because gorr
had been killing all the gods originally there was
going to be a deleted scene talking about gorr the
god butcher during the moon knight finale but just
because of the release timing and them not being
sure when the movies were going to come out they
just decided to get rid of that you also notice
one of the big changes here is that they actually
bleed all the color out of the frame when you see
a lot of these gorr scenes like when thor and
valkyrie and jane foster store are fighting him
you see there's basically no color aside from
their weapons in the trailer it sounds like
that's going to be involved with the power that
he gets from the necro sword like something about
the sword just bleeds all color out of reality the
scene with him seeing this giant dead rat looking
alien is actually one of his friends in the comics
is right out of the comics is him witnessing
gorr's destruction it's meant to be the god of
this other race of people so this is him just
learning about what's happening with gorr the god
butcher but it sounds like just like in the comics
in the trailer in the movie gorbal have already
been busy killing gods for a long time when thor
learns about him for the first time there's a
bunch of scenes of jane foster store and arthor
fighting zeus's men it just seems like it's this
giant contest in this giant council of gods in the
comics they actually call that the god head it's
basically meant to be an assembly of all the most
powerful gods of the mcu we just got a first look
at boss the panther goddess who's black panthers
god the god of wakanda it seems like this scene
is happening in this giant arena here where all
these people are assembled and why would you do
something like that like you do this big build up
they have this funny moment with zeus making thor
all naked this is probably happening before gorr
shows up and kills a bunch of these gods like this
probably turns into a giant kill box why would you
bring all these gods together in the same place
if not to make it easier to kill a lot of them
zoom in enhance on the tattoo on thor's back this
actually seems like a brand new thing i think the
idea with the tattoo is that it's just a memorial
to his history like all the great things that
have happened to him the big battles that he's
participated in like it's meant to be hardcore
but yes you are seeing a version of loki's horns
as a tattoo on his back so imagine how loki or
the loki variant from the loki series would feel
about this when he sees thor again like wait what
you got a tattoo of me on your back we get a brief
teaser for some of the powers of the necro sword
he smashes it into this planet here you see all
this energy arcing out from around it they have
this giant battle against him and the whole thing
with valkyrie using zeus's lightning bolt i think
is because zeus probably gets killed during the
events of the movie like they're portraying him
in kind of a funny light because they're kind
of buttering you up before he gets this big wtf
ending when gorr shows up because we're talking
about greek gods it also seems like they're trying
to make a wonder woman joke here because it looks
like the ropes that he's whipping around are like
wonder woman's lasso of truth rippling with energy
there's only a little bit of new footage with the
guardians of the galaxy but i think that's because
they're focusing on all the brand new gorr stuff
and all the brand new stuff on mount olympus but
just in general this trailer is meant to give you
a much better idea of the story which is basically
the gorr the god butcher comic book story married
with a lot of the mighty thor story from the
comics with jane foster become a version of thor
i'll do a couple of bonus videos about the bigger
concepts but if you have any questions about
what's going on in the trailer or you spotted
really big easter eggs that i didn't talk about
in my previous thor trailer videos just write
them below in the comments my full obi-wan kenobi
episode 1 and episode 2 video we'll be posting
later this week we're probably going to get a
mandalorian season 3 trailer there'll be a couple
other big star wars trailers so make sure you have
alerts enabled for my channel so you don't miss
those everyone click here for my other big thor
love and thunder trailer video and click here
for my brand new black panther 2 first look at
namor thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!